uh hi everyone my name is Yuna Lee I'm
I'm a TA for this course and it's it's
my first time giving a lecture so
hopefully everything goes well
so
yeah uh we're gonna be talking about uh
the second edition of Advanced Metal
learning topics I think on Monday
Chelsea talked about uh
memorization and task Construction in
metal learning and
today we're going to talk about
large-scale meta optimization
as a quick reminder homework 3 the one
on language models is out this Monday
and it's due in a week
so we're going to start with kind of uh
a big picture question about
metal learning and why we should even do
it uh
so we can think about uh
learning methods as being on the
spectrum between hand-designed priors
and data driven priors and there's kind
of a continual shift downwards towards
more data-driven stuff
so for example a long time ago people
used to do uh
directly modeling image formation and as
a slightly more data-driven way they
uh
constructed hand-coded features and
extracted those out of actual data
points
and then people started doing end-to-end
learning of the features themselves and
by for example fine-tuning from
pre-trained image edit features we
the pre-trained networks contain
a very good prior about what natural
images are like
and it's more of a data driven prior and
the reason we keep going downwards is
that
more data-driven approaches are more
scalable so in a sense if you keep
throwing more real data at them they get
better and better at encoding real
priors and
being effective in Downstream tasks
so really the one of the pitches for why
we should be doing meta learning is that
it's even more data driven than
end-to-end tuning of uh Network
and because the thing is we directly
learn the learning algorithm themselves
and a question that we should kind of
stop and ask is
we go downwards because we want to scale
better we want to
have something that may start out not so
good but as it sees more data it gets
better and better and we should ask do
meta learning methods actually work at
scale
so for the metal learning algorithms
that you've seen in the class like
mammal or you know prototypical Networks
can you actually
give them more data and have them work
better and really the answer is kind of
no
so if you if you like become if you were
lured into this course from the promise
of like
being very data driven and being able to
learn from all the data that you have
then
it doesn't really scale so
uh in today's lecture we're going to
talk about why that's the case and what
we can do about it while still staying
in a Metallurgy setting
So the plan for today is we're first
going to motivate large-scale meta
optimization what it is and why we
should do it we're going to look at some
applications of this and then we're
going to look at two approaches in
particular that can handle uh large
scale settings
and by the end of the lecture we won't
have time to go into deep detail into
most of this stuff but at least the goal
is to know scenarios where
large-scale stuff makes existing metal
learning approaches fail and broadly
understand some techniques for
handling those types of scenarios
yeah so
so I think we can roughly summarize a
lot of the metal and learning approaches
as doing direct back propagation
so this is the Black Box model that you
learned in homework one I believe and
it's just a network that can take all of
your Source I mean support data and your
query data and outputs predictions and
in the same way uh mammal also mammal
and all the optimization-based
approaches
here too you uh just it's one big
computation graph that takes in your
sourcing query data and then in the end
you back propagate and apply towards
kind of automatically uh does the
metaling for you
and the same story is with
non-parametric methods
so the the commonality here is that all
these methods are
first constructing a task learning
computation graph and then back
propagating through the whole thing
and this is kind of a general recipe
that you can apply to any sort of
learning computation graph that you come
up with
and it's simple in the sense that
autograd does all the work for you
so it's good that it's done
automatically but the core issue with
this is that your memory cost scales
with the size of your computation graph
and there are learning settings where
you would like to have a bigger
computation graph which is what we're
going to talk about today
so to give you a rough sense of uh how
big computation graphs are in general
this is from uh metal learning paper
the details don't really matter uh
the standardly used uh four layer CNN
has about 10 to the five parameters
some Works use bigger networks like wide
resonates those have a bit more and yeah
resnet 12 has about that's 10 million
parameters which might seem like a lot
but the computation graph only involves
at most one feed forward one back prop
and then another V forward which uh
you don't have to multiply this by a lot
to get the whole computation graph and
this is
a very toy example from the official Pi
torch tutorial this is for learning I
think cpar
and the network size is a bit less than
10 to the seven
and we trained this for five epochs uh
five epochs with C4 is about four
thousand steps
so if you try to calculate the size of
that entire computation graph it's very
big I think it's about 100 gigabytes I'm
happy wrong but yeah it's definitely
bigger than whatever GPU you have
so in these sorts of scenarios if we
want to consider learning algorithms at
this scale what can we do because we
can't directly apply a direct back
propagation
uh so again uh
the
three big meta learning approaches that
we've covered in the course so far
they can all be summarized with this a
big uh not so big flearn which is the
inner loop computation graph with some
sort of meta parameters data
and we construct this and back propagate
through the whole thing
uh so a question for you is when might
this flearn be kind of too big to apply
direct back propagation
foreign
I'm just
in any sense well what is kind of an
inner loop learning algorithm that you
would like to use but we can't directly
back propagate their little thing it's
pretty common yeah
yeah that's definitely yeah if you have
a model that's bigger than your GPU it's
yeah
uh
yeah this occurs like maybe too commonly
for you to give uh
any answer kind of really works
so yeah
flearn is too large when we have a big
Network and or in many gradient steps so
even if your model is small if you take
too many gradient steps the whole
computation graph is the size times the
number of gradient steps so it's too big
another possibility is that if your
inner optimization includes second order
optimization so you if you have to back
propagate through a second order
optimization then that is another
scenario where it can be too big so for
example if your inner optimization is
meta learning itself and you want to
Meta Meta learn how to metal learn
better
I don't recommend you for this but if
you wanted to do that this would be too
big and you couldn't use a direct back
propagation
and when we consider bigger flearn then
we get to consider a lot more
interesting meta parameters data so I'm
going to show you a bunch of examples of
meta parameters
um
so first of all we have things like
mammal where
uh
to summarize again we learned the
initial parameters
so this whole thing is the outer loop
objective and in the Inner Loop we uh
do a gradient step with respect to the
loss the trading loss
and as you've seen in homework 2 you can
also learn the learning rates
which is it was a component of the
computation graph before but we can
include it as The Meta parameters and
directly learn that so that uh your
final performance is better
now the point I want to make
is that really any any components of
your computation graph can be a meta
parameter so for example
uh
like building on the learning rate
example your Optimizer can also be
something that you meta learn
and yeah really what is an Optimizer it
something that ticks in your gradients
ticks in your current parameters and
gives you something else and this
doesn't necessarily have to be hand
designed
uh
to get even more
strange we can actually meta learn the
loss function so by loss function I'm
referring to things like the cross
entropy loss and the way you would do
this is
what a loss function is is it takes in
your predictions and your true labels
and gives you a scalar and that's you
back propagate from that
so for example a way you can learn a
loss function is
have a
have an elf Phi is that we call it a
network that takes in uh
yeah you just it has uh two inputs it
has you input your predictions and the
grounds with labels and it predicts
something and then you treat this as you
would uh a regular loss function and you
back propagate through it and do
everything else
and
that's possible you can also directly
learn the data set so the thing that you
feed forward through your network
doesn't have to be your original data
the way this can work is you can
so for the case of images
um
yeah you can just have uh four
dimensional tensor that acts as your
data set and you can directly apply your
augmentations or anything else as just
shoot this like your data and you can
also optimize this so that learning is
better
in the downstream
and there's even ways to paramet oh yeah
sure
example of when you would want to learn
a loss function because it seems like
you would have to have a real loss
function that you actually are trying to
minimize and you're trying to learn this
intermediate loss function to to get
there right
yeah so
we always uh need a loss function in the
Outer Loop but in order to minimize the
services
so every loss function that we use
anyway is a proxy so if you think about
classification
what we really want usually is accuracy
and that's not a loss function that we
can use because it's not that
propagatable
and so we use cross-entropy loss as a
proxy for that but it may not be the
case that cross entropy is
the best thing to optimize to get high
accuracy so this kind of searches in
that space
that maximizes the accuracy
so we can't back propagate through the
accuracy but we would minimize this
objective
which uh
incorporates the accuracy
does that make sense
we uh yeah we learn an L so that running
gradient descent on l
results in bigger accuracy
don't you have to take the gradient of
the accuracy with respect to this
oh okay that's the division so
the point I'm getting at is we don't
necessarily have to back propagate
through this and there are ways of uh
optimizing for things that you can't
differentiate through and that's the
stuff I'm going to talk about later okay
they're shooting the outer walls
oh yeah there should be an L here yeah
that's a typo
so if we are learning the loss function
could we also like learn like how to
work human rights but like if we go to
law function then we can learn like
how to like regular rice and so that in
the outer loop it works well but it
doesn't like overfit to the
yeah absolutely uh learning a
regularizer is kind of a variant of
learning a loss function where your
total loss function is like an original
loss plus something else
or we should be repeating questions yeah
how would you
take your
because
[Music]
more formula foreign
how do we Define the search space for a
loss function and that's really up to
you in a sense you can do a search over
like finite set of candidates you can
just
make your search space the set of like
networks that have the same input output
structure
um
[Music]
okay the question is how what does it
mean to optimize the data set and yeah I
agree that this is kind of a foreign
concept
so what you can do this is like the
simplest way to do it and you can just
directly parametrize uh four-dimensional
tensor with the interpretation that each
each dimension in the batch Dimension
corresponds to an RGB image
and you feed this forward through your
network as if it were an actual image
and you back propagate I mean yeah
you do gradient steps with respect to
the loss and then you get final
parameters and we optimize for
Downstream validation loss or
performance
so it's kind of like we're trying to
find an example which is performed the
best for our current model
we're looking for the examples
so that if we try to minimize the loss
for those examples we would get better
performance later on
but if it's like the less extreme
example could you do like a learning
augmentation instead of just creating
the destiny oh yeah absolutely you can
have the the question is can you learn
instead augmentations yeah you can
start with like actual images and learn
mild documentations to the images so
that you get better performance I think
a couple of teams are working on that as
a final project
yeah I'm going to move on in the
interest of time
so we're going to move on to
in this large-scale meta optimization
setting
what are some applications that people
have previous papers I've looked at
uh
so one application is hyper parameter
optimization people don't usually call
this meta learning but you can view it
as in the same
rough frame
so by optimizing hyper parameters
so uh
yeah first of all when we're optimizing
hyper parameters the inner loop is
basically a big learning STD chain and
of course we can't directly back
propagate through that
and by optimizing hyper parameters
existing Works have shown benefits over
random search
you know better lstm hyper parameters
and
in a state the same framework you can
also uh optimize the hyper parameters of
a data augmentation Network which starts
to look a lot more like parameters than
hyper parameters and things that you can
optimize in this way are things like
Dropout fraction learning rates
yeah things like that uh your the weight
that you give to regularization terms
so hyper parameter optimization is one
application another another is data set
distillation which is closer to uh
optimizing data sets as
we talked about before
and here
the method in this specific paper it
matches the gradients
of with the gradients with respect to
your synthetic data to the gradients
with respect to real data so
we're making synthetic data points so
that it results in similar gradients as
the real data set
and in this way you can actually
compress existing data sets
like 10-way classification problems with
a lot more
images per class into single images per
class and gets
pretty good performance it's not
definitely not as good as the original
data sets but you can get like 99
accuracy on mnist after training on
those 10 images and so on
yeah everything makes sense right
yeah you can also learn optimizers uh
this kind of Builds on you know learning
the learning rates and
parametrizing the optimizer as a neural
network so one way one very simple way
to
parameterize an Optimizer is as a
network that takes in for each parameter
the current gradient and the momentum
which is like a moving average of your
previous gradients and
outputting an update
this paper uses a more complex
architecture which takes in gradients
momentum the second moment and also
takes in the current training and
validation loss in tensor shape and
gradient Norm
so by looking at this in a meta learning
setup
your Optimizer can be it can take in a
lot more information than traditional
optimizers do which usually just to use
like the current first and second order
moments of the gradients
and they're learned optimize their works
at the scale of big breast nets for many
training steps so
here they're they're optimizing a resnet
for 10 000 training steps which is
obviously too big to apply direct backup
application through
and
they even use it to train itself
so what this means is on a set of tasks
they
train and Optimizer so that it gets
quick at learning these tasks and then
they totally re-initialize and then use
that Optimizer to optimize the outer
loop loss
which is pretty uh meta
yeah another thing you can do is neural
architecture search yeah this here we'll
see a way to parameterize a neural
network this is one way to do it other
works use other ways uh hear what they
do is they have an RNN that outputs the
parameters of your neural network I mean
yeah the the parameters of its size
so it outputs things like number of
filters filter height width stride for a
CNN
and
when they apply this to an RNN it
produces this very big thing which like
no person would kind of come up with
from first principles but this seems to
work better better than things like
lstms or grus
and this was in 2017 so this is a long
time ago but
at the time they achieved
state-of-the-art results in terms of
error rates on I think this is imagenet
I'm not sure
so yeah through these applications uh
we
we didn't we don't really have time to
go into depth on any of those but
hopefully you're kind of convinced that
large-scale meta optimization is
possible and
now we're going to look at some
approaches to doing that and I'm going
to talk about two approaches uh some of
the works I've talked about before use
one of these two and some use other
approaches which I'll briefly touch on
but
yeah that's
what we're going to talk about are there
any questions
another question about the learning tool
that Optimizer for people
so is it that my documentary is being
learned simultaneously the main training
is happening is it definition of offline
data in this Optimizer first
yeah the question is uh is the optimizer
learned alongside training and I think
in this paper the answer is yes
and you train a little bit update the
optimizer and then train a bit more and
so on
[Music]
um
so how is it able to like do predictions
on unseen things every time like full
optimization because
trading
isn't like have experience
right yeah the question is how does it
basically generalize to
places in the Lost landscape where it
hasn't seen and the answer is uh
so first of all let's say our Network
learned the identity function of the
gradient so it just passes forward the
gradient that works well by itself and
it generalizes
so there is a pretty simple solution
for The Meta optimization that
generalizes and because we're
explicitly optimizing for the outer loop
loss for
after you take gradient steps do you
generalize
that's what kind of the secret sauce
that makes it
learn generalizable updates
if that makes sense
without seeing what happens everything
is unseen for the optimizer
oh my previous answer may have been
Computing so it does reset so
after you train on a couple of runs we
go back we completely reset the inner
loop parameters and then learn again
from there
so yeah whatever time step it arrives at
it's probably seen that before
okay
um yeah let's move on
yeah so we're going to talk about a
couple of approaches to large-scale meta
optimization
and
yeah before
laying out the
direct approaches to how to do this
we're gonna kind of visualize what
happens with unrolled computation graphs
so that means when you optimize some set
of parameters continuously we can unroll
that computation graph into kind of a
sequence of parameters
so here we let's say we start from the
parameters by one and we do a gradient
step and get Phi 2 and we keep doing
that so these blue blocks are your
parameters your inner loop learner
parameters and then we finally get the
validation loss at the final time step
so our goal is to modify something about
this inner loop learning
system so that the the red node
becomes low
and from this Viewpoint we can
view a lot of the things that we talked
about as
possible meta parameters as follows so
the initial parameters it's there and
your Red Dot the final validation loss
is there so yeah that's what makes the
back propagation hard to yeah through
the whole training Loop
and for learned losses I think you
mentioned regularizers
or optimizers uh
the The Meta primers that you're
optimizing are they appear in the
mapping from a parameter to the next
parameter like this
and for data set distillation and
learning augmentations
the
The Meta parameters appear as the input
to your network
and for the architecture it's kind of
embedded inside the your parameters it
kind of interacts in a way that can't uh
represent with arrows
so kind of the point that I'm getting at
is
you can view all of these as
suffering from from the same core issue
which is that you have to back propagate
through this very long chain
to get from the red to the green so we
can't apply direct back propagation
uh so yeah we're going to talk about
truncated back propagation
and yeah from the visualization from
before
really why we consider large-scale meta
optimization and these specialized
approaches is that we just can't fit all
of these parameters into a GPU
so truncated back propagation is quite a
simple algorithm it's
uses a time length so let's say three
and as you feed things forward as you uh
optimize you just detach everything
before three steps ago
and that makes it so that you can apply
direct back propagation to the the green
nodes that are nearby but you have to
just ignore everything from before
and
yeah
um
so when we're considering uh time links
like this uh what could happen if we use
too short of a t
like what would be the trade-offs
yeah the answer yeah you said we about
propagations faster but we just don't
learn things from earlier and yeah
that's exactly correct
uh
we basically
can't learn any long-term dependencies
if we have a Time step of three then we
only optimize things that are like
beneficial in the short term with
while uh ignoring everything every way
in which the green nodes can help the
red node down the feature
uh implementing this is quite simple
this is for an RNN and it's slightly
different from that visualization but
the main trick is that as you feed
things forward you just detach things
when they become too old and your GPU is
happy with that
so for truncated back propagation
it's very simple so here also as in
direct back propagation Auto grad
handles everything as long as you detach
things
wow when you have to
the problem is that first it's a biased
estimator
so you're not getting the true gradient
of green with respect to red
so that bias can harm performance
and
more specifically we cannot take long
range dependencies into accounts which
when we're meta learning with big
computation graphs really what we want
is to learn something that kind of keeps
on being useful as you keep taking steps
and this is kind of undesirable
uh one point that can be good and can be
bad is that by using different tea you
can uh have a trade-off between
correctness and memory cost so
in the limits of the maximal T you get
totally unbiased totally not ignoring
long-range dependencies but you
need a lot of memory and with sort of T
you
ignore all the long range dependencies
but it's uh easier to compute yeah
the inner loop of enamel
so this this is specifically foreign
s and
no I I should have been more clear about
that this works in any uh
inner optimization inner sequential
optimization Loop and the blue things
can be parameters
where moving to the right would be a
step of gradient descent
you keep Computing gradients every three
time steps or do you just forget
it
yeah you would detach
everything from before
so let's say you take 100 gradient steps
at the 100th gradient step before you
back prop you would detach from like the
97th brilliant step
back so you would still use the
parameter values but the gradients just
wouldn't flow past that
um
the question is how would you detach
the previous parameters
yeah just calling detach should suffice
and
you could
speak English
list or something
oh God yeah so the question is how do
you keep track of these variables yeah
you would need to keep something like a
tuple or a list too yeah
could you explain again what you mean by
a long range let me see
is what do I mean by long-range
dependencies
so let's say you
this instead of five steps is like a
hundred steps
there's gonna be a way that the input at
the first step
influences the output at the last step
but by truncating somewhere in between
the gradient doesn't flow from here all
the way to the beginning so we kind of
ignore all those long range dependencies
in terms of time steps
now let's uh move on
and yeah we're now going to talk about
gradient free optimization
and this just uh directly avoids the
issue of
not being able to back propagate through
the graph because
we can do optimization without using the
gradients
so the algorithm that we're going to
talk about is evolution strategies
though there are other gradient free
optimization methods that aren't this
uh it's roughly inspired by like
biological evolution
where you know the
whatever has the highest survival rate
just keeps expanding
and
yeah nature doesn't that propagate
so yeah we're just gonna directly use
that trick
yeah the question is is this like
genetic algorithms
I think it's exactly the same thing I
that might be false
but yeah they're very elated at least
um so how Evolution strategies works is
roughly like this and will uh walk
through this step by step
so first of all we initialize the
parameters
so in this visualization imagine that
your parameter space is two-dimensional
and one
any parameter combination is a single
point in this and the lost surface is so
that the lighter regions are better
losses
so what we do is we initialize the
the distribution of parameters uh mu and
sigma and then we just sample
a bunch of parameters like this
yeah so
let's say
yeah let's say uh that is the reason
that we want to arrive at and our
initial parameters are something like
this
so we've sampled seven points and we
after sampling a bunch of particles we
evaluate and get the top and with where
a small end is smaller than big n
so in this case let's say uh
we had
seven particles and we want to
pick the top war that would be something
like this
so we
evaluate this and get the top four and
then we just plug in the average and
variance of the the top population
so now we would
sample from this distribution in the
Next Generation
and we keep
yeah we just keep doing this we sample
again from here maybe we get something
like this
take the top four
and the population just keeps converging
to this without ever having to back
propagate or need the gradients of this
loss surface
it was pretty exploitative
yeah the question is won't this get
stuck in local Minima
um
it definitely can uh I would say like
that's something that you can also say
of stochastic gradient descent though so
any kind of local search method can get
stuck in local Minima uh for this what
people usually do is they add an
exploration term so you kind of increase
your variance whenever you're too sure
so that can kind of mitigate that but
yeah it definitely can be possible so if
this region was like a lot better it's
definitely possible that you're just
stuck here forever
yeah
so uh we're gonna walk through a very
simple example of this where
we optimize the learning rates instead
of this uh 2D service
so for optimizing the learning rates how
this would work is you initialize your
average learning rates and noise
probably to uh
a reasonable value for a learning rate
so you know something like .001 is
probably reasonable
and we just sample a bunch of learning
rates
from that distribution
and then the inner loop is where you get
to do basically anything you want and
here we do
using each learning rate we initialize a
network and then run SGD and then we
evaluate All Those runs and then pick
the top end with with the best accuracy
and then with those uh top candidates we
take the average and variation variance
of
the learning rates and then we keep
repeating again and
as we do this we converge towards Better
Learning rates for
whatever data sets or architecture that
you are considering
do you mean
[Music]
I'm talking the the question is is SGD a
small number of steps it can be anything
you want I'm considering like actual
training very long many epochs and the
reason we can do that is that
we choose the best members without
having to hold the entire computation
graph in memory
okay
yeah here uh here's a conceptual
question uh what would happen if we try
to instead of learning meta learning the
learning rates use this exact algorithm
to optimize the initial parameters as in
memo
will be very inefficient because the
number of parameters
right yeah the answer was that it'd be
very inefficient because the number of
parameters is large yeah
yeah I definitely agree with that I
would phrase that as because your
parameter Space is really high
dimensional
we would basically never observe uh a
good outer loop loss because
just by applying uh High dimensional
noise we would never arrive at uh
any sort of good parameters so this
would never learn
it would learn in the limit of infinite
time but yeah it'd be very uh
sample inefficient
so the advantage of evolution strategies
is that oh yeah question so it's high
Dimensions
so I wanted to ask a question is there
any way to divide the dimensions
and work on optimization for a
sub-dimensional spaces and then maybe
somehow merge it for the find Optimum
for the
or is there any approach
yeah the question is can we
because we have a high dimensional space
can we divide the dimensions and
optimize separately
um
so I think that can work if the loss
surface is factorized in the sense that
if you optimize this
set of parameters it has no effect on
this
but
we're going for interdependency as well
in the emerging stuff
is there any also something is there any
research on this area
not that I know of
yeah you would have to be relying on
some sort of uh Independence conditions
though yeah I'm not sure how that would
work or aware of the latest works
so do we usually use this evidence of
strategies
oh this is all happening in the Outer
Loop at the moment
so in the example here
yeah the inner loop was just SGD and we
were using Evolution strategies in the
in the Outer Loop
but
of course you could use Evolution
strategies in the Inner Loop
is the greatest decision
so the question is
if we use Evolution strategies in the
Inner Loop and we want to do direct back
propagation in the Outer Loop
um
yeah to my knowledge there's no way to
back propagate through Evolution
strategies so you would have to use some
outer loop optimization method that
doesn't require gradients so you could
do inner loop Evolution strategies and
outer loop Evolution strategies that
would work
and
um
greetings
um could you repeat that what are we
comparing what's the difference so for
each iteration of update Independence
what's the difference between the
communication costs of evolution and uh
so the question is about comparing the
computational graph of evolution
strategies and direct back propagation
okay uh
so in terms of computation graph
yeah
length Evolution strategy is just
requires your
a copy of your parameters that can be
updated so it's like your network times
one whereas for direct background
application it's your network times the
number of steps because you have to keep
everything in memory so that you can
back propagate
so in that sense this is constant and
direct backup propagation
because your story of gradients and
stuff like somewhere for each parameter
you are just trying you trade you are
just iterating over the we are just
reading right you have stored it just
once so you're just essentially creating
a copy of your architecture and for each
parameter you are actually storing its
gradients so why do we need to store it
every time we need to go back
[Music]
so it's just a reading cost not the sort
not actually writing cost back to the
Matrix
so is the question that
[Music]
for a direct back publication yeah
yeah I think your
talking about uh gradient checkpointing
which is
yeah that would uh
save memory cost at the expense of time
cost and if you start using that then
back propagating through a long chain
would be feasible but the time cost
would make it
pretty quickly unfeasible
because you would have to store
parameters and then
you have to basically go back and repeat
everything you've done yeah
right
and here they could be done independent
but all the parameters
right here it can be completely in
parallel and don't distort anything
thanks
a preparation between the number of
candidates with simple and the dimension
of the
parameters were optimized using another
evolutionary
so you're talking about large and and D
which is two here right
um
the dimension of alpha
okay yeah the question is about the
proper ratio between big n and Alpha's
Dimension I don't think there are very
strong guidelines
but
it definitely can't be the case that uh
your lost surface is very high
dimensional and very curved and you use
and that's much smaller than that so if
you have a million dimensional parameter
space you can't use n equals 10. to
explore that space
um
like having a dodging process that kind
of predicts what's the
foreign
do you want to compare with respect to
like time and space or performance
the other like because I know for for
like gaussian processes you could
depending on the sampling charge
a global Optima
um but also it becomes much much more
expensive dimensions
larger
when would you decide to use Evolution
versus
yeah that's that's a good question
yeah the question is when would you
decide Evolution strategies or gaussian
processes for these sorts of settings
and
yeah honestly I don't really have that
good of a sense of when what would be
better
so for calcium processes your
prior in likelihood have to be
very well suited to whatever problem
you're using and we generally don't have
something like that for high dimensional
data like if
if our task in the Inner Loop is image
classification large scale image
classification I don't really know how
we would do that with calcium processes
but if you have a really good prior and
likelihood model for reaction processes
then that can be better
and storage wise
I think
something like this would scale a lot
better
because we don't have to store or you
know keep track of all the data points
that we have
yeah so uh the
the main advantage of evolution
strategies is that the memory cost is
constant with respect to
the number of gradient steps that you
use basically the
whatever you do in step two it's
its Size Doesn't Matter to
what you need to approximately
differentiate with respect to that
and another Advantage is that you can
very easily parallelize this
so as soon as you sample your different
particles you can run everything
completely separately and all you need
is the final output so if you have a lot
of parallel computers then
this can be Well Suited
and you can even consider
things in the Second Step that are
non-differentable
because we don't rely on gradients at
the moment
so any sort of you know sampling or
discrete operations in the Inner Loop
is very compatible with Evolution
strategies
the main uh disadvantage of evolution
strategies is that it struggles with
when uh
the parameters the MU or Theta whatever
you want to call it is very high
dimensional or when it's lost surface is
very complex
as in the example of optimizing the
initial parameters with uh Evolution
strategies
there are a couple of other approaches
to large-scale meta optimization
though these are a bit less commonly
used but they're the math is pretty
interesting so I'll very briefly touch
on them and
there are papers on the bottom that you
can read if you're interested there's
implicit differentiation
uh what this does is
it leverages the assumption that you
converge to
an actual Optimum and differentiates
through that optimality uh condition
to
get yeah you get the full meta gradient
without storing anything
but yeah but the assumptions that go in
may not be satisfied in all cases
so it's not perfect but it it seems to
work sometimes
and
another approach is forward mode
differentiation
so this is
back prop is basically the chain rule
where you
you leverage the fact that the output is
one-dimensional
so
given the all the terms in the chain
rule if you start multiplying from the
back you always have a term that's
Dimension times one so it's always sort
of linear
but if you multiply from the forward
you get these terms that are quadratic
in the output sizes or parameter sizes
which costs a lot more compute but
this has the advantage of not having to
store everything
so because everything that you want to
want to multiply is there at each step
you can
just yeah you can forward prop as you go
forward
without having to store everything so
this is
it's advantageous when you don't want to
store everything but
yeah there are cases where this too is
to uh
too costly
um yeah that's roughly
that's what we have today so we've
talked about a large scale meta
optimization we motivated the problem
and why existing meta learning
approaches kind of fail in large scale
settings and we talked about some
applications and two approaches
truncated back propagation and gradient
free optimization
and yeah the goals were that
we know scenarios now where existing
approaches can fail because of scale and
we understand in a broad sense some
techniques for this problem setting I
hope that's been accomplished
yeah we have some time for questions if
you have any
okay
anyone try something like greedy
algorithms like uh we first optimize
like foreign
oh what we do
so you're talking about like a two-stage
method where you do three steps first
and then completely disregard what
happened and then do three steps again
by propagate through all the computation
group
yeah I think what you're talking about
can be viewed as a truncated back
propagation
in a sense
uh
yeah you're choosing to ignore the
future influence of your first three
steps right
but that influence is something that can
still exist
so in the ideal case we would want to
track this influence
but yeah you're making the simple buying
choice to ignore that I think that's
just exactly a truncated back
propagation
like truncating uh assume that uh
like the result from the bigger steps
also applied to the first few sets but
like if we start from the first
and then uh
optimize for the following steps next
that you always
um
make sure that we won't get a degenerate
solution because we can always make the
following step do not
um could you repeat the degenerate
solution part
um like when we're doing a truncated
propagation uh we like for example in
the like the in the slice we plot the
result from them
last three steps to the
uh steps that is to touch from me in a
little optimization
but if we start from the beginning and
oh
and then
maximize for the following steps we
always can make those
those points that do nothing so
we have the uh exactly the same result
as
we only do the first few steps that we
just optimize
okay so is the setting that after the
three steps do you remember the
parameters
of the last third step or do you like
re-initialize with something here
because if you remember it there is some
sort of long-term influence and if you
re-initialize you're just doing two
tasks sequentially and
in the latter case we can
just consider this a two task setup
yeah we can take this offline later
um yeah if there are no
from this group article question which
is if you're doing model development and
you're thinking well maybe I should
optimize my initial parameters maybe I
should optimize my learning rate but
then you're also changing the model as
you're going to model okay can you use
these strategies or is it better to just
do the simple thing every time
and you know under what circumstances do
you optimize
yeah the question is when you're doing
model development
does it make sense to keep your
pre-optimized learning rate after you
change the model uh I think that would
very much depend on how much you change
the model if you don't change it by that
much I'd assume that the optimal hyper
parameters are quite similar so using
the previous solution as like maybe the
initial
thing for your hyper parameter
optimization can be a reasonable thing
to do if you make really big changes
maybe starting from scratch
would be better
yeah I think it
very much depends on how you set things
up